okay well I could tell you one of two
things like to tell you the standard
sort of classical view of what a vacuum
is but for me that's not so interesting
I'd rather tell you a sort of
non-standard quantum mechanical view of
the vacuum because we you know we
typically we think of the vacuum as
being some of the quiet dull place with
not much going on quantum mechanically
nothing could be further from the truth
essentially the vacuum is extremely
lively place
yeah the vacuum is pretty
straightforward isn't it it's where
there's nothing there there are no
particles you you can't breathe in a
vacuum you many of us have seen the
experiments where you you take air out
of it out of a jar and you see it
there's a flame and the flame gradually
goes because first of all the oxygen is
taken out so you you're extracting
something out from a body and eventually
when there's nothing left
that's the vacuum until you go to the
world of the quantum and it seems to
just blow up in your face this vacuum
the vacuum in quantum theory isn't quite
like that indeed that in quantum theory
the vacuum doesn't have any particles
that you and I detect that's so that's
common that that's still the same but
what it does have are these what you
call virtual particles these are
particles which because quantum
mechanics works on principle of
uncertainty these particles can pop up
into existence and then disappear again
over a very short period of time I mean
the way I like to picture it is if
you've ever seen I'm a celebrity get me
out of here for example these guys they
sort of have these that sort of tubs of
full of eels and snakes all wriggling
around like and they always have to get
any or something for mini and well that
sort of picture of all these eels and
snakes wriggling around is actually how
you would picture the vacuum quantum
mechanically it's that lively so the
reason it's so lively is is is what's
happening is you get these particles and
antiparticles they literally pop into
existence and then pop out of existence
again and this happens continuously at
all points in space within that vacuum
so it's kind of like this is continuous
sort of hive of activity where particles
are going in and out of the vacuum
popping into existence and then going
out of existence again
and we live it's been tested the the
idea that these particles are there has
been tested it was originally devised by
a number of eminent physicists people
like Paul Dirac and Richard Feinman
Schwinger had the idea that there were
these things that could pop up into the
vacuum so you have that you start off if
you like with nothing and then you think
of it as there's no particles there and
then these things are popping up and
disappearing again gives the vacuum and
energy and we know it gives the vacuum
an energy we've actually tested this
experimentally there's something known
as the Casimir effect where you take two
parallel plates in a vacuum very close
together if you think classically
nothing should happen but quantum
mechanically because of this vacuum
energy and this vacuum energy is sort of
affected by how far apart these plates
are that gives you a force between the
plates and actually it's been observed
that the plates actually moved together
so we actually really you know we've
experimental tested this vacuum energy
as a real thing and it's a very it's a
way in which we do characterize the
vacuum now that it has this energy this
inherent energy it's there and our
universe has a vacuum energy if what I
think is a vacuum is in fact this
seething mass of particles popping into
and out of existence
why does affect you behave like a vacuum
why does a jerk crumple when I suck all
the particles out of it why aren't these
virtual particles still striking the
inside of the vessel and keeping the
vessel inflated and things like that the
virtual particles that are present don't
produce forces that are strong enough to
to overcome those kind of pressures that
you're talking about they are they're
they're all around us I mean if the
world of quantum electrodynamics is
correct and our understanding of the
quantum world is correct everywhere
around us there are virtual particles
being created and annihilated all the
time and in fact some people actually
believe that it's the presence of these
of this force this kind of Casimir as an
energy you can associate with it got
like a Casimir energy it's called some
people believe that that is accounting
for the expansion of the whole universe
it's called a cosmological constant and
so it's having a huge effect on large
scales but on small scales it turns out
the actual contribution of these in any
small region is
actually relatively small and so it's
not big enough to affect the kind of
process that you've just personally just
been describing so if you took
everything else in the universe
everything you thought you saw all the
planets all the stars all the dark
matter there's still something left over
and that's the vacuum energy now one of
the great mysteries of physics is that
the vacuum energy that we see that we
think is out there it's only very very
small the density is very low
theoretically we expect the density to
be very high and we really don't
understand why it's like that can you
create a super vacuum where even virtual
particles don't exist that's just that
would be a super-duper
vacuum not just a super vacuum I'm not a
wall I don't think so because any
process and quantum quantum mechanics
can occur at any on any scale at any
time at any temperature quantum
fluctuations can occur there's there's
nothing to stop them and so because they
can occur they will occur over some time
period or something will occur and so
you will get these fluctuations popping
up I'm not I'm not aware of any
situation where I can actually suppress
the fluctuations in themselves